The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
GREG HUTKO: Hi, and welcome
back to the 14.01
problem-solving videos.
Today I'm going to do Fall
2010 Problem Set 7,
Problem Number 2.
And we're going to work through
both parts A and B to
begin with, so I'm
going to read the
beginning part of the problem.
Suppose Napster's considering
selling music via email.
There are two types of users,
students and non-students.
Each non-student has an inverse
demand function of 200
minus x and each student has an
inverse demand function of
160 minus x, where x is the
number of songs delivered by
email, p is measured in cents.
The marginal cost to Napster of
sending an additional song
via email is 0.
Suppose Napster can identify all
users as either students
or non-students.
If Napster offers a fixed number
of songs per year to
each person, what is the profit
maximizing level of
songs offered to a student
and a non-student.
In other words, what is the
equilibrium level of output
for each type of person under
first degree price
discrimination?
Part B is going to ask us, given
the equilibrium level of
outputs that we've calculated,
what is the dollar price
charged to students and
non-students per year?
Now what this problem is really
asking us about, it's
asking us about a situation
in economics
called a two-part tariff.
Now in some cases, when you have
two groups of consumers
that have differing demand
functions, a monopolist can
actually capture the
vast majority of
the consumer surplus.
Or in most cases, all the
consumer surplus if he can
differentiate between
the two groups.
So in this case, Napster is
probably going to set up a
situation where they can
differentiate between students
and non-students.
So if they can discriminate by a
student by having them enter
their school ID or their school
email address, then
they'd be able to do the
situation that we're doing for
parts A and B.
The two parts of a two-part
tariff, the first part is an
access fee that's equal to
the consumer surplus.
So you can say to a consumer,
sure, you can have this set
bundle of songs, this
set number of songs.
But you're going to have to
pay all of the potential
benefit that it would
bring you.
So if it's going to bring you
160 units of benefit, we're
going to take that from you and
we're going to give it to
the producers instead.
The second part, in addition
to the access fee, the
producer has to decide the
price per unit when the
consumer is consuming
the bundle.
And they also have to decide
how many songs to bundle.
The way the producer makes this
decision is by setting
the price per unit equal to the
marginal cost. So they're
basically going to say, I'm
going to throw in as many
songs into this bundle, get you
using as many of the songs
as possible, or listening to
the songs as possible.
But I'm going to only thrown
in as many songs until it
starts costing me more than it
could potentially bring me by
capturing your consumer
surplus.
So we're going to set the price
per unit equal to the
marginal cost equal to
0 in this problem.
Now looking at our graph, I've
tossed up the demand curves
for the student and
the non-students.
And what's going to happen
in this problem is in the
equilibrium case, our supply
curve is actually straight
along the x-axis because our
marginal cost is equal to 0.
So if this was a competitive
equilibrium, the producer's
surplus would be equal to 0.
But what we're going to do
in this case, or what the
producers are going to do in
this case, is they're going to
say I can bundle for the
students 160 songs, so that
the quantity produced is here.
I'm going to charge you the
marginal cost equal to 0 for
each song you listen to.
But then I'm going to come back
and I'm going to make you
pay all of your consumer surplus
each year to download
those 160 songs.
So again, I went to
the marginal cost,
which is right at 0.
Then I set the price
where it intersects
with the demand curve.
And then again, I said that
we're going to charge an
access fee equal to that area.
The same thing is going to
happen to the non-students.
In addition to charging the
consumer surplus for A, we're
going to make a larger bundle
with 200 songs, so that we can
capture this additional consumer
surplus out here.
And I'm going to break this area
up into two pieces called
B and C. And you'll
see why I'm doing
that in just a second.
So for part A, how big are we
going to make the bundles for
the students and the
non-students?
The bundle for the students is
going to be equal to 160.
And the bundle for the
non-students is going to be
equal to 200.
Now for part B, we know that
we're going to charge a price
per unit equal to 0.
We just need to calculate what
the access fee for each of
these groups is going to be.
And so the access fee for the
group of students who have a
song bundle of 160 is just
going to be the area of
triangle A. So their fee is
going to be consumer surplus
of students, which is equal to
A, which is going to be equal
to 1/2 times 160 squared.
So we're going to charge the
consumers a fee that's going
to be equal to 12,800.
And a common mistake on this
problem would be to just have
this answer and put
dollars here.
But if you look back on the
problem it said that all
prices are given in cents.
So we know that the fee
for the students
is going to be $128.
And now we know that the fee for
the non-students is going
to be higher because their
consumer surplus is greater
when they have a
bundle of 200.
So the fee for the non-students
is just going to
be the consumer surplus
of the non-students.
And that's going to be the area
of A plus B plus C. Which
again, that's going to
just be equal to
1/2 times 200 squared.
So in this case, our fee for the
non-students is going to
be equal to $200.
So when the monopolist has a way
of telling who's a student
and who's a non-student, then
they can charge the
non-students a higher price
because their demand curve is
further up and they're willing
to pay for more
songs within a bundle.
Part B is going to ask us, or
part C, moving on to part C.
It's going to ask us, what's
the maximum price that
students are willing to
pay for this bundle?
So for the 160 song bundle,
we're asked, what's the
maximum price students
are willing to pay?
Well, if we charge them a
price higher than their
consumer surplus of $128, then
they're just going to drop out
of the market.
They're going to say, I'm not
going to even buy this bundle.
You're taking away all of
the benefit and then
an extra one penny.
It's worth it for me to just go
someplace else and take my
money elsewhere.
So the answer to part C, the
maximum price you can charge a
consumer in a student for the
160 song bundle is just the
$128 that we calculated
before.
Part D brings up an interesting
implication,
however, for the non-students
who can look over and see the
maximum price that we're
charging the students for
their bundle.
Part D says, what is the gross
consumer surplus that
non-students enjoy if they
consume 160 songs per year at
the price from C?
What is the net consumer
surplus?
So gross consumer surplus is
just going to be the situation
that we had before.
In this case, we're looking
at this point here.
We're dealing with
the non-students.
They're going to now be
consuming the 160 song bundle.
The consumer surplus for this
group of students is going to
be both A and B. So working with
part C, we know that the
gross consumer surplus for the
non-students when they're
consuming 160 songs is going
to be the area of A plus B.
And we know that the net
consumer surplus, they're
going to be charged a fee
equal to A. So the net
consumer surplus is just going
to be what we calculate for
the gross consumer surplus
minus the fee
the area of A, 128.
So even though the non-students
will get no
consumer surplus in net if
they go with the 200 song
bundle, maybe if they go with
the 160 song bundle, they'll
be left over with some
consumer surplus.
Now to calculate the area of A
plus B, all we're going to do
is we're going to say that we
know the area of A plus B plus
C. Now we're just going to
subtract out the area of C.
And if we were to go back to
our demand curve for the
non-students, plugging in the
quantity of 160 into that
demand curve, we would find
that it intersects
this axis at 40.
So the area of A plus B plus C
is going to be equal to 200.
And then the area of C is going
to be equal to 1/2 times
40 squared.
And so that means that the gross
consumer surplus for a
non-student is going to
be equal to $192.
So that's the area of A
plus B in our diagram.
Now to find the net consumer
surplus, we're just going to
subtract out 128.
And we're going to find that the
net consumer surplus for a
non-student who's consuming
160 songs is going
to be equal to $64.
So if the monopolist was still
to price the same prices that
they had before, if they were
to make the 160 song bundle
$128 and the 200 song bundle
$200, in that case, all of the
non-students would look at their
two choices between the
bundles and they'd say, even
though this non-student bundle
is targeted towards me, I'm
better off in net consumer
surplus if I go with
the bundle that's
targeted toward students.
But now the monopolists
aren't going to be
stupid in this situation.
They're going to go back and
they're going to think, well,
if you're going to go and buy
the non-student bundle, then
what I have to do is I
have to make sure--
if you're going to go back and
buy the student bundle, I have
to make sure that the
non-student bundle gives you a
higher net consumer surplus, so
that you're still willing
to buy the non-student bundle
with 200 songs.
Part B asks us, what is the
maximum price Napster can
charge for 200 songs per year
if it offers 160 songs per
year at the highest price that
students are willing to pay?
And so simply put, what they
can charge for the 200 song
bundle is they can charge for
an area of A and C. So we're
going to subtract out.
We have to leave the
non-students with at least
enough consumer surplus
for the area of B.
We know from our previous
problems, we know that the
area of A is just going to be
equal to 1/2 times 160 squared
plus 1/2 times 40 squared.
This is the area of A and this
is the area of C. So we can
find that the maximum fee
is going to be $136.
The other way of calculating
this is to just say, well, I
know that the non-students are
starting off with 200 hours of
consumer surplus.
I know that I need to leave
them with at least $64 of
consumer surplus.
So you can just think
intuitively.
You know the maximum price
is going to be $136.
And so what we're really going
to look at in this situation
where they can't discriminate
between the students and the
non-students, this is the price
that they're going to be
able to charge for the
200 song bundle.
For the 160 song bundle, they
can charge the maximum price
the students are
willing to pay.
And if we were in a scenario
where there were only two
customers in this market, one
non-student and one student,
then we could calculate the
overall profits for the
monopolist. And so in this
scenario, the overall profits
are going to be $264.
The last part of this problem
is going to give you another
scenario that the monopolist
might consider.
The last part of these problems
is going to ask you
to look at, what happens if
instead of designing a student
bundle that has 160 songs, what
happens if we design a
student bundle that instead is
only going to have 140 songs?
And again, when you're designing
this bundle, you're
going to have to plan the prices
so that only students
will want the 140 song bundle
and only non-students are
going to want the
200 song bundle.
And the process is going
to be the same.
So we're going to stop
here on this problem.
And just to summarize what we
looked at here, we looked at
the consequences and the
implications of having a
price-discriminating monopolist.
When you can
actually discriminate, you can
capture all the consumer
surplus and you can charge
different prices to different
groups in the market.
But when you can't discriminate,
what you have to
do is you have to make packages,
bundle them and
price them, so that the
consumers will discriminate
themselves by picking the bundle
that gives them the
highest net consumer surplus.
I hope you found this part
of the problem helpful.
And go ahead and continue
through with part I and check
your answers against
the solution.